have you read her Rand Atlas Shrugged
that's the one yes yes it is few
American authors have shared the initial
commercial success much less the immense
staying power of ein Rand author of the
novels The Fountainhead and Atlas
Shrugged and a host of non-fiction books
that continue to sell hundreds of
thousands of copies a year a quarter
century after her death Rand is still
showing up all over popular culture I
was shrugged
earlier this year late night TV host
Jimmy Fallon did a bit where audience
members eight pages of rants free market
friendly books for sustenance as the
stock market tanked
give me two fountain hits wait I'm sorry
you're getting two yeah what I'm hungry
for knowledge allusions and references
to ran to bound author philosopher and
female comb-over pioneer iron ran this
is the story of Maggie Rourke an
architect who refused to compromise
throughout the ages the finger painter
the play-doh sculptor the Lincoln logger
stood alone against the daycare teacher
of her time she did not live to earn
approval stickers she lived for herself
reports and variety in Hollywood
Reporter insists that true believing ran
fans Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie are
very close to rolling film on an a-list
version of Atlas Shrugged in fact half
of Hollywood seems to be devotees of the
one-time script girl for Cecil B DeMille
brand even has fans in Congress Iran
does the best job of making the moral
case for democratic capitalism more than
anybody else in an age of massive
taxpayer-funded bailouts and proposed
tax hikes on the wealthy people are
looking for an alternative and finding
it in rands work over the past year the
economist than others have reported
sharply rising sales of rands books
never a critical darling ran stock is
even rising
the Intelligencia two new books goddess
of the market and I'm ran in the world
she made take long serious and generally
sympathetic views of her life at work
what's so appealing about ran and why is
she hotter now than ever
we asked reason contributing editor
Cathy Young who like ran left the Soviet
Union for the United States she carved
out a very unique niche with that
romantic vision of the individual with
her defense of capitalism with her
defense of reason all of which really
stands out in twentieth-century culture
her 1958 novel Atlas Shrugged has even
provided a major meme of going Gault in
the novel the productive members of
society tired of creating inventions and
companies that get taken over by the
government retreat to a secret mountain
hideaway called Galt's Gulch in a
country where the government seems
hell-bent on taking over everything from
the financial sector to automotive
companies to health care more and more
people are asking why should they
continue to produce anything if it will
only be taken away via taxes regulation
and destructive government policies
panicky about it I think it is
definitely worth remembering as a
cautionary tale whether or not anyone
actually ends up going golf this much
seems clear Iran will be even more
relevant to the 21st century than she
was to the 20th for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie